- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk about modern campaigns.
In particular, we're
gonna talk about the cost
and the duration of modern campaigns,
especially in the United States.
And this graphic here, which comes from
the Campaign Finance Institute,
and it's based on data from
the Federal Election Committee,
it clearly shows how the cost
of congressional campaigns
have increased dramatically since 1986.
If you look at nominal dollars
for the House of Representatives,
so this is just the actual dollar amount,
you see it's almost grown
by a factor of four or five.
But even if you adjust it for inflation,
the cost has doubled for
your average House campaign.
And you see a similar trend
in the Senate campaigns,
where, even adjusted for inflation,
the cost of your average Senate campaign
has increased by 50%.
Now, this also does not capture
all of the outside money,
things like super PACs and whatever else.
If you fast-forward to 2016,
your average Senate campaign
costs a little over 10 million dollars.
But there's about that much money,
approximately 10 million dollars,
that also comes in from
things like super PACs.
And so it's totalling
near 20 million dollars
for a Senate campaign, on average.
And so particularly competitive campaigns
can be a lot more than even that.
And if you wanna talk
about really big money,
you just have to look at
presidential campaigns.
So this right over here is
the last presidential campaign, in 2016.
And you can see that Hillary Clinton's
candidate committee money was
over half a billion dollars.
She actually had a good
bit more than Donald Trump.
And she had a good bit more outside money.
But the entire Hillary Clinton campaign
had a nearly 800 million dollar budget.
And if you combine Hillary
Clinton plus Donald Trump,
you have a total of 1.2 billion dollars
for the 2016 campaign.
In 1980, the total was 92 million.
So, more than a 12-fold increase.
And even if you were to
adjust for inflation,
which these numbers are
not, but even if you did,
you would see a several-fold increase
in the cost of a campaign.
So when you look at
these types of numbers,
there's a couple of interesting
questions that come up.
One is, what is the money for?
Money for what?
Well, there's many answers to that.
One is, is that, especially
in a presidential campaign,
and to a lesser degree in
a congressional campaign,
the campaigns have to pay
professional, full-time staffers.
So campaign, campaign staff.
You'll often have a lot of volunteers,
but for example, Hillary Clinton, in 2016,
had approximately 4200 people on payroll,
where about 800 people were working
directly for her campaign,
another 400 with the
Democratic National Committee,
and roughly 3000 people with
state Democratic parties
in the battleground states.
And beyond, on the staff,
you also might have paid
political consultants.
Now, what do all these people do?
Well, they come up with
a campaign strategy.
Some of them will do polling,
to understand the sentiment
in the larger population
on specific issues or on the candidate.
And they will do a lot of
campaign advertising and marketing.
Advertising.
And so the staff will think about,
well, what kind of
advertising do we need to do?
And then a large chunk of the money
actually goes to the advertising itself.
Advertising.
Especially in mass media,
if we're thinking about
radio and television.
Now, an interesting question is,
given that in the 2016 campaign
Hillary Clinton outspent
Donald Trump by so much,
how was he able to
actually win that campaign?
Well, there's several
possible explanations to that.
One is, is that Donald Trump was
very effective at
getting himself attention
that he didn't have to spend money for.
On top of that, a trend that has emerged
really since the 2008 Obama campaign
is the increasing use of
social media in campaigns.
Before social media became a major player,
most of that energy really
was in mass media advertising.
But now with social media,
you could cater a message
to specific groups.
You could focus your message.
You could activate your base more.
And so more and more, social media,
which is currently a lot less expensive
than, say, TV advertising,
is becoming a bigger and
bigger part of campaigns.
Now, a last answer to the
question of why so much money
is that you have long
campaigns in the United States.
In some countries, the campaigns might be
anywhere from two to six weeks.
In the United States, the formal campaign,
if you think about the first primaries,
it's in February of an election year
in a presidential cycle,
and then the election is in November.
So you're looking at
roughly nine to 10 months
from the first primary and
caucuses to the election.
But well before the first caucus,
you're going to have
the various candidates
raising money and trying
to get name recognition.
And so the actual campaign
and money raising,
for a lot of these candidates,
might be closer to two years.
And so you can imagine, if
you're spending two years
with consultants, trying
to do advertising,
just so you have a showing
in some of those first
caucuses and primaries,
well, that's going to
cost you a lot of money.
Now, it's for you to think about
whether these are good or bad things.
Many people would argue that having
such a long election cycle
doesn't allow a lot of
focus on other things.
Especially if someone's the incumbent,
if they are campaigning the whole time,
can they even govern?
And then another argument
against all of this money
is it might put too much influence
in the hands of people who can give money.
I'll let you think about that.